au coeur du donbass ces pompiers
approvisionne des civils qui manquent
désormais de tous
ont libre de l'eau aux gens on les aide
carrasso viande qu'il n'y a plus d'eau
chaque jour ils se rendent dans les
secteurs qui ont le plus de besoin cela
fait un mois que les systèmes de pompage
et de filtration ont été endommagés par
les combats
tiens moi nous avons une liste avec les
adresses
montre moi la liste
donc ses habitants se regroupent à la
hâte pour récupérer de l'eau potable
mais les manques se font toujours sentir
dit au maire qu'on a besoin de deux
camions par immeuble ils savent ce n'est
pas assez je viens de tellement loin
pour récupérer un peu ils ont coupé tout
le gaz tout bloquer et c'est tout qu'est
ce qu'il croit le président et les skis
est-ce qu'il pense avec sa tête ou avec
son derrière
pourquoi il a tout coupé
si quelqu'un se trouve dans les couloirs
où les appartements décents d ici
[Musique]
les bombardements s'intensifient
une bombe à sous-munitions a créé l onde
de choc
oui une ouragans après un court instant
à l'abri les pompiers doivent rouler
vite pour porter secours car une
quinzaine d' incendies se sont
déclenchés
on arrive
[Applaudissements]
l'unité 1 est en chemin
après la chute de les sites chances que
les forces russes avancent vers leur
objectif le contrôle de la totalité du
donbass
oh